in the year 1014 Byzantine Emperor basil
ii defeated the bulgarian army and
captured fifteen thousand prisoners he
could have killed them but he had a
different idea he wanted to weaken his
opponents for decades to come
so he ordered that 99 out of every 100
prisoners be blinded the 100th to be
spared one eye to guide the rest back
home forcing their communities to care
for them for the rest of their lives
today humans are subject to an attack
just as cynical as this by a league of
super villains called NTDs one in seven
humans on the planet suffers from one or
more entities more than the entire
population of Europe they do
unimaginable damage by crippling
countless people they destroy billions
of dollars in income each year weakened
communities and slow progress what are
these monsters straight out of a horror
movie
seeking to wreak havoc on our species
[Music]
NTDs are caused by a vast range of
different parasites such as worms amoeba
bacteria or viruses the symptoms they
cause the justice diverse and truly the
stuff of nightmares
some like hook worms compete with
children's brains and bodies for
nutrition stunting growth and impairing
intelligence some entities cause
blindness as a result of orful eye
infections other parasites can find
patients to bed for months and damage
internal organs often shortening
lifespans drastically yet others cause
horrible disfigurements that lead to
social stigma a life lived in shame and
unemployment there are also a few that
are incredibly agonizing they cause
continuous itching or horrible pain in
fact let's introduce you to one of them
dracunculus Asst if you accidentally
drink water infected by it you won't
notice anything for a year until one day
you suddenly see a blister on your leg
the world breaks out of the skin to
release new larvae the only way to
remove it is to slowly put it out of
your leg Center by centimeter over the
course of several weeks because
dracunculus is now up to a meter long we
can all agree that we should kill such
parasites with fire that's why we
declared war on them pleading to
eradicate most of them by 2020 and we
tried doing that very hard in 1985 there
were 3.5 million cases of tranquilizers
all over the world in 2015 there were 22
we killed 99.999% of these little
monsters it will be the first parasite
we eradicate for good very soon so even
if they don't generate a big headlines
like Ebola did actually amazing things
have happened when it comes to NTDs all
NTDs have one thing in common they
preferably attack humans who live in the
most isolated communities and who are
least able to defend themselves there
are villages that are 500 kilometers
from the nearest health facility with no
anywhere so even if a remedy is
available what if it means going on an
odyssey to get it to the patients this
called for an attack using brute force
to stamp out NTDs once and for all
what's possibly the biggest medical
program in human history was launched
unmatched in scale organizations from
all fields are working together right
now to eliminate ten of these NTDs
forever ironically every NTD is in fact
preventable or treatable but most of
them can only be controlled by giving
medicine to every person in all
high-risk areas that means millions and
millions of doses of medicine often for
several NTDs at a time over the course
of years in countries where there is no
infrastructure governments and health
organizations just couldn't do that by
themselves here humanity got an
opportunity to show off what the
industrialized production of medicine
can achieve the pharma industry stepped
in to distribute the necessary drugs for
free and promised to keep doing it until
those ten diseases are gone by 2020
nearly 18 billion dollars worth of drugs
will have been distributed the largest
drug donation the world has ever seen
they also helped make sure the drugs
actually get to where they're needed in
2015 alone these treatments reached over
850 million people more than the
population of the EU and the u.s.
combined bad things happening generates
headlines hundreds of millions of people
overcoming extremely destructive
diseases in an unprecedented act of
cooperation doesn't the stories like
this one and not told often enough good
things happen all the time
moving humanity closer to a future with
no suffering so if you or one of your
friends are in need of uplifting news
share this video with them we as a
species ready can do great things with
no other motivation than to help each
other it's good to remember that from
time to time
this video was made possible in part by
a grant from the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation and your support on
patreon.com if you want to help us make
more videos you can do so here if you're
disappointed by the lack of disturbing
facts in this video here's a playlist
about the end of everything
[Music]